The average
number of requests
needed to properly display
a website rises constantly
and has recently risen over 100.
That means on average, a website
requires over 100 requests
to display correctly.
Things are getting
a little crazy.
Remember that HTTP/1
does not work well
with lots of requests.
Fortunately, HTTP/2 too
has come to the rescue.
We'll look at some
problems of HTTP/1
and how HTTP/2 is solving them.
One of the reasons we
have so many requests
is because of
head-of-line blocking.
We talked about this earlier,
but it's so important
let's briefly go over it again.
Head-of-line blocking is when
one request is blocking others
from completing.
A browser will open at most six
connections to the same server.
That means at most
six requests can
be in flight simultaneously.
At the very least, you'll
have to wait for the request
to be sent and then the
response to be sent back.
These two together are
called the round trip
and the round trip time can take
between 20 to 50 milliseconds
on a good connection.
Let's do some quick math.
Let's say a site needs
to send 100 requests
to load completely.
We can handle six
requests in parallel,
which means ideally
each connection will
need to make 17 requests to
download all 100 requests.
With each request
having a round trip time
averaging roughly
35 milliseconds,
this yields 525 milliseconds.
About half a second of waiting--
of doing nothing.
And this assumes that actually
transferring the requested file
doesn't take any time at all.
If the file being
transferred is large,
then this number will
become a lot bigger.
This round trip
time is an average.
If there's an unstable or
slow internet connection,
things only get worse.
Head-of-line blocking is
a disaster to good loading
performance of a website.
With HTTP/2, we
don't have to worry
about head-of-line blocking.